today on the matt walsh show a video of
a business owner in michigan is going
viral he is
defying his state's shutdown order and
paying a hefty price for it but his
message is inspiring and worth listening
to so we'll play that today and talk
about it also
five headlines including supposed
conservatives urging republican voters
in georgia to stay home
and hand the senate to democrats and
also another
anonymous racist note we've got another
one these things are everywhere it's
just that they always
turn out to be fake uh plus our daily
cancellation and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know one of the most important
things in life just to be a happy person
what little i know about that subject is
you got to get a good night's rest you
got to be able to sleep um and you know
i could tell you that i'm i'm on the
road a lot i do a lot of traveling
and it so i'm on a lot of different
mattresses
and they're they're certainly not all
the same to say the least and it really
determines what kind of mattress you're
on will determine
what kind of sleep you get and that's
going to determine so much about your
about your well-being and your health
and everything else
that's why you've got to look into helix
sleep i've got a helix sleep mattress
myself i cannot recommend it highly
enough helix sleep has a quiz takes just
two minutes to complete
i've done it it matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you if you like a
mattress that's really soft or firm
you sleep on your side or your back or
your stomach if you get really hot while
you're sleeping with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste
you don't need to take their word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine so all you got to do
is go to helixsleep.com
walsh take their uh two minute sleep
quiz it really does just take two
minutes
and with that information they're gonna
find a mattress
that is customized perfectly it's gonna
it's gonna feel like it was made just
for you which it was
um and that's that's been my my own
experience with the helix
sleep mattress we got it uh we've had it
now for months and i have
i i haven't slept better in my life than
i have on the helix sleep mattress right
now helix is offering
up to 200 off and free pillows with all
mattress orders
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
walsh that's helix sleep.com
welsh for up to 200 off your mattress
order so the mayor of
austin steve adler had an urgent message
for the residents of his city a few
weeks ago via facebook video
he said that everyone needs to stay home
and
this is this is not a time to relax
here's a little bit of that message this
is very important stuff
that you need to take very seriously
watch the thrust of the most important
messages trying to get out to the
community right now is
that our numbers are increasing and
everybody has to be aware of that
and then we need to you know stay home
if you can
do everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to to relax we're
going to be looking really closely
yes everyone needs to stay home except
we've learned that
when a democrat mayor or governor says
everyone it can roughly be translated to
everyone except me as it turns out adler
delivered that message telling everyone
to stay home
from his vacation home in mexico he
traveled there with a number of
friends and family on a private jet he
made this trip only a day after hosting
a wedding reception for his daughter
with 20 guests at a hotel in the city so
he gathered with 20 people and then
traveled
to another to a foreign country and then
came back here
adler now joins the likes of dc mayor
bowser who traveled to
delaware a so-called high-risk state to
attend joe biden's victory speech that
was essential travel though you
understand of course
essential also nancy pelosi who went to
get her hair did
at a salon that was supposed to be
closed same for chicago mayor lori
lightfoot
violating her state home order for the
same reason mayor of philadelphia who
was
who banned indoor dining but traveled to
maryland to dine indoors anyway
and of course gavin newsom and his
infamous indoor dinner party
and new york mayor bill de blasio who
went to the gym
as the pandemic raged and governor
blackface of virginia
who was spotted maskless at a beach
governor cuomo who invited his elderly
mother for thanksgiving even after
telling everyone else not to be around
their families on thanksgiving
and the mayor of denver who told
everyone to avoid travel
right before getting on a plane to
travel and los angeles county supervisor
sheila cool who we uh
you heard about a few days ago who dined
outdoors hours after voting to ban
outdoor dining and the list goes on mary
margaret olhan
with the daily caller has a
comprehensive list on their website that
you should you should go check out
it's even worse than you think i mean
those are just a few of the the low
lights
there's many more that have been caught
but somehow
steve adler manages to rise to the top
of this heap of hypocrites he was on
vacation in a foreign country
while telling everyone else to not so
much as leave their homes
this is hypocrisy so blatant as to
almost be cliched
and it brings to mind again and this is
a fact we cannot forget
that the people behind these
restrictions are not impacted by them
also the people cheering them on in
media
are not impacted by them when the
talking heads on cnn night after night
lecture americans for not obeying for
not following the state home orders for
opposing the restrictions
they deliver the lecture from a
television studio
in which they are paid to work i'm paid
to work in this studio
even if nashville gets shut down again i
could still go to work
somehow my job is considered essential
you know um who am i then to earn a
paycheck at my essential job quote
unquote
while telling you that you should sit
home and let your children go hungry
now i'm not the most empathetic guy in
the world but that would be cruelty and
selfishness beyond even my capabilities
if you can believe it and the thing is
um my job is essential you know that's
true my job is absolutely essential
to me i doubt it's very essential to
your life
but it's essential to my life and my
family it's how i earn a living
it's how i put food on the table it's
how i pay for the bill to doctors when i
when my children are sick
so it's very essential to me
your job is essential to you all jobs
are essential
that's not a bumper sticker slogan they
might put that on the poster boards at
the protest
but it's also true it's more than a
slogan all
jobs are essential because someone
depends on it for survival
it might be only one person depending on
it could be a house full of people
it could be more than that depending on
what the job is but someone does
someone depends on it and that makes it
makes it essential by
any reasonable measure by any reasonable
definition
of the term but don't take it from me i
want to play for you what is perhaps
i think the most compelling piece of
video to come out of this crisis
this is from michigan where a ban on
indoor dining
is in effect um which is of course
decimating the restaurant industry in
the state and
financially destroying thousands of
people now outdoor dining is still
allowed
but it's 40 degrees right now in detroit
last i checked
you know people aren't eating outside in
40 degree temperatures also
not every restaurant has the space to
set up outdoor dining you hear people
sometimes say well just you just do
outdoor dining
well that assumes first of all that you
you have space outside that you own as a
restaurant
where you could put tables a lot of
restaurants don't have that
and also the state of michigan has very
specific rules
about what qualifies as outdoors and
what doesn't
and we know anytime the government gets
involved you're gonna even
simple things become complicated and now
we need
pages and pages of rules to just tell us
what outdoors
is and uh and a lot of things that seem
like they're outdoors actually aren't it
turns out for example a brewery in the
state this is from an article in
eater.com
a brewery spent all summer setting up an
outdoor area with heaters and
and and you know kind of like a large
sort of barn-like structure
protection from the elements a lot of
air circulation the whole nine yards
but when the state passed its indoor
dining bin the owner of the restaurant
discovered that according to their
definition
his outdoor space is actually indoors
so he wasted all that time and money for
something he can't use
and they didn't tell him he couldn't use
it until the very last minute
you spent all that time making it and
then they come and say oh you know what
you can't this this doesn't count
the article says that he's quote
disappointed
something tells me that that's probably
an understatement if it were me i think
i'd be less disappointed
and more burning with the fiery rage of
a thousand suns
oh but by the way um it does count as
outdoors if you put the diners in
plastic domes
okay so those those small you know those
maybe you've seen them the pl
small plastic claustrophobic
bubble domes those that's fine you can
do that that counts as outdoors
the virus can easily be spread somehow
this is considered safer than just
having people sit
inside a building and somehow a plastic
dome
outside a plastic dome is considered
outside but a large
physical structure with airflow and
heating that is not outside
it's all arbitrary and outrageous of
course and people's lives are being
ruined because of it
which brings us then to the video i
mentioned dave morris the owner of
dnr daily grind restaurant in michigan
has decided to keep his restaurant open
for indoor dining
uh he's not shutting down he's been
fined a thousand dollars a day
since the new order went into effect i
think he's up to a six thousand dollars
now in counting
but he has no plans of backing down and
when a local news station
showed up to report on the story dave
appeared suddenly on camera
and uh here's what he had to say
is everything okay okay my government
leaders have abandoned me
are you are you the owners of four
trillion dollars of
stimulus money i gave it to who special
interest groups and campaign donors i'm
dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey
we got a government that has taken the
stimulus money
they gave it to special campaign donors
they gave it to special interests
they abandoned me and they had put me in
a position where
i have to fight back okay so do you feel
that this is the right thing to do
absolutely
i feel everybody needs to stand up hey
listen there was enough money to give
every family
every family in this country twenty
thousand dollars to go home for two
months
they chose to give it to special
interest and campaign donors
the kennedy space center and they
abandoned us
so you could have given me money i'd
gladly walk away for 60 days and let
this virus settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
state order this isn't an order this is
a conspiracy this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be free
i got patriots coming out supporting me
that is uh great stuff and everything
you said there's
correct his math is correct too by the
way three trillion dollars divided
between all the families in america all
the households about 110 120 million or
so
would work out to 20 or 25 000 for
everybody
now i'm normally the last person to
advocate for government handouts but
this is not a handout so i'm still not
advocating for a handout
the government is telling people they
can't go to work and earn money
the government is shutting down entire
industries you can't do that and then
give people a couple thousand bucks and
expect it to last for months or longer
the government is stealing from the
american people telling you that you
can't work
and then giving you nothing in
compensation that's stealing
we're not talking about welfare here or
debt forgiveness for student loans or
anything like that
we're talking about the state depriving
its citizens of the ability to work and
earn a living
the state then has an obligation to
compensate for lost wages
that's the point that dave morris is
making and it's a good one
and that's what i like about this video
too dave is not an activist
he's not someone showboating you know or
strutting for the cameras
he doesn't have a poster board uh there
are no slogans here
you can tell he's not looking to be
famous he's not looking for attention
and actually he's perfectly willing to
cooperate with the stay-at-home orders
and the dining ban and all that
but he can't do it if he's not
compensated he can't just sit at home
with no money and no business
he's not willing to do that and he
shouldn't be nobody should be willing to
cooperate
with this scam that's why we need more
dave morris's in the world a lot more
the government has seized power that it
will not relinquish easily in new york
just to show you how bad it's gotten
they're now doing sting operations and
arresting restaurant owners who serve
food inside
yes sting operations they're sending in
undercover police
to order like a hamburger and if they
get the hamburger then
the person's going to jail the powers
that be are
desperate to retain the control they've
gained over
our lives men like dave morris are
desperate
just to survive a clash between these
two groups is coming
and i know whose side i'll be on
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so there was a rally down in georgia
yesterday with lynn woods supposed trump
supporting attorney
and sydney powell and some others and
they were urging republicans to
potentially
not vote in the georgia runoff here's
the report from daily
it says georgia based attorney lynn wood
an alleged trump supporter urged trump
supporters on tuesday evening in the
state to
quote not vote in the senate runoff
unless the two republican senate
candidates publicly demanded that
georgia republican governor
brian kemp call an emergency session in
the legislature to investigate alleged
voter fraud however
news reports that surfaced late on
tuesday evening appeared to show that
wood has a history of voting for and
donating to democrats
eric erickson he's a conservative
commentator
highlighted alleged political
contributions that wood has
made to democrats um and so he lists a
bunch
march 2008 would contributed to barack
obama
um allegedly uh and then a bunch of
contributions to obama john edwards um
and it goes on from there so this has
been this has been the you know the news
people are arguing about right now
that this attorney who's telling people
republicans potentially
stay home and not vote is you know has
supported democrats now for me
that's not i i don't really care about
that that's not the point for me i mean
there's a lot of people who
10 years ago 12 years ago 14 years ago
or whatever
uh supported democrats and don't anymore
that's that's that's
relatively common and there's good
reason for that and the democrat party
has just gotten crazier and crazier with
each passing day
and so there are more and more people
leaving as they should so that for me is
not the point
yeah i i really don't care who he's
voted for in the past
um the point though forget about what
he's done in the past
let's look at right now anyone i don't
care who they are
and what their name is if they are at
all even entertaining the
idea that republicans should stay home
and not vote in georgia whoever does
that
is a con artist and a scam artist
you are you are handing the the senate
and control the government the entire
government to the democrats
i mean we it it it is hard to even
imagine
how bad it could be if the democrats
control
everything now i've been the first to
say in the past that
you know some of the some of the
apocalyptic sort of handwringing we do
over elections is overplayed because
you know you win some you lose some
democrats win republicans win
it's not going to be the end of the
world just because the wrong party is in
there
but with that said this would still be
very
very very bad news for the democrats to
control everything you know the
democrats
are out for revenge they're out for
blood we know what they want to do
they've already made it clear they want
to defund the police
they want to pack the court you know
they want to add senate seats
statehood for you know dc puerto rico
they want to do things to to make it so
that they never lose again
and that's just to start with so yes
keeping keeping the senate out of their
hands out of their control is
priority number one right now and i'll
tell you what's going to happen
you've got some of these con artists
telling republicans to stay home
in georgia and so what's going to happen
is that democrats will win
that that's that's what happens if your
voters stay home the other team wins
so the scam artists are saying stay home
and don't vote
and then democrats win and then the scam
artists will say you see they cheated
that's why they won no they cheated
because you told everyone to stay home
you were working for the other side and
pretending that you're working on our
side
and then they're gonna say you see they
cheated now just donate some more money
to me
personally put my name make it out to me
personally
and i'll help save the republic
it is such an obvious transparent
scam and i i don't know how anyone could
fail to see it there is
no defending this whatsoever if you're
telling people to stay home in jordan
telling republicans to stay home in
georgia
you are handing the senate to democrats
and everything that happens after this
is on you it's your fault socialism
comes to america
you can't turn around and complain about
it and try to fundraise off of it
donate to me i'll help fight socialism
you put socialism in there
it's absolutely infuriating
all right let's go to number two uh
article in the houston chronicle about
the upstart conservative social media
app parlor i don't know if you've been
on this this site yet parlor
i recently started an account but things
are not going terribly well i suppose um
mr chronicle says anyone following
following the hashtag sexy trumpgirl
hashtag on twit
on parlor a social media site
increasingly popular with conservatives
got an eyeful
one recent thursday evening as images of
topless women and links to hardcore
pornography websites appeared at a rapid
fire rate
often more than one per minute i kind of
feel like if you're
clicking on that hashtag that's probably
what you were looking for so probably
not a surprise
but anyway it goes into how um
pornographers
allegedly supposedly are taking over the
site now you have to
there's always a grain of salt when you
see media articles about parlor because
it's
known as a conservative social media app
and the media doesn't like it for that
reason and so
they've got a they've got they have a
reason to make it sound
worse than it actually is i will say i
don't know about the pornography aspect
of it i haven't seen that
for me the problem with parlor is um
it's got two two big problems
number one there's there's no innovation
with the function of the site
so you look at all the the social media
sites that have that have
taken off and managed to seize the size
of the market
you know a portion of the market there's
something about them that's a little bit
different
functionally there's some sort of
functional innovation with parlor there
isn't it's just sort of a twitter
knockoff
and the other problem too is that is
that it's kind of an echo chamber right
now
if you go there everybody is
conservative just talking
we're all just talking to each other
about how right we are which is kind of
nice
every once in a while but it's not
nearly as fun
so that's um that's a real problem then
the third problem parlor runs into is
that
they don't have billions and bills this
is the main problem they don't have
billions and billions of dollars which i
think is what you really need
in order to have a chance to um to make
a dent
in twitter or facebook but um
i think they're worth supporting because
i support the i support the idea i like
what they're trying to do
at least all right so we've got we got
ourselves number three here
another anonymous racist note this one
was allegedly left under the door of a
woman
in an apartment complex in boston
um also maga country in boston just like
chicago
she she posted the screenshot of the
letter typed up very nicely
uh it's a typed letter that someone
supposedly left for her
and and she also and you know i'm not
saying you could draw any conclusions
from this at all
but she also included along with
the screenshot of the racist letter in
the twitter thread she included a link
to her business
that's it so she's basically saying hey
i was a victim of a racist hate crime
and also
also by the way buy my stuff while
you're here
anyway so the note says you seem to have
no respect for others huh
you seem to think you can move into a
new building without abiding by the
rules of morality or have any concern
for anyone else but yourself
who uses a blender at 10 a.m that does
i mean using a a blender at maybe 6 a.m
i think
might violate the rules of morality
depending on how thin your walls are
10 am i think you're in blender
territory
um you're playing rap music so early in
the morning
please put away the n-word music only
n-words listen to n-word music
can you listen to something more
peaceful more calming it's very rude
it's entirely rude please learn to have
some respect
and please stop having sexual relations
so wait hold on
actually it says what it's supposed to
say is please stop having sexual
relations so loud i promise you it's not
that good sweetie you don't need to wake
everybody up learn to have manners and
be respectful
what it actually says though is please
stop having sexual
rations so loud
sexual rations
that's um i mean that's one way of
putting it you know you go to your
spouse
hey honey i like to get one of my sexual
rations this evening
uh another weird thing though is that
she has pronouns in her bio
and she identifies herself as quote
queer earthy
afro latina so i tell you what the weird
thing about that is that
it's i don't know if you've noticed this
it's always the most
liberal left-wing far-left people who
get these racist notes have you noticed
that it's always like left-wing
activists
people with pronouns in the bio they
have the worst luck
they're always the ones who happen to
stumble across
these incredibly racist people that none
of us are meeting the rest of us we
never meet these people
it's only them it's only the the far
left pronouns in bio
people who meet the the most racist ones
it's really bad luck
i guess or it's just a total scam
i'm thinking more of the latter number
four barack obama had something to say
about the defund the police
slogan uh and what he had to say about
it has upset a lot of people on the left
anyway who are now
sort of turning on him and saying what
does he know
um and uh here's what he had to say
it's no different in terms of ideas if
you believe as
as i do that we should be able to reform
the criminal justice system
so that it's not biased and treats
everybody
fairly i guess you can use a snappy
slogan like
defund the police but you know you've
lost a big audience the minute you say
it
which makes it a lot less likely that
you're actually going to get the changes
you want done
but if you instead say let's reform the
police department
so that everybody's being treated fairly
you know divert
young people from getting into crime and
if there's a homeless guy
can maybe we send a mental health worker
there instead of
an armed unit that could end up
resulting in a tragedy
suddenly a whole bunch of folks who
might not otherwise listen to you
are listening to you so the key is
deciding do you want to actually get
something done
or do you want to feel good among the
people you already agree with
and if you want to get something done in
a democracy
in a country as big and diverse as ours
then you've got to be able to
meet people where they are and play a
game of addition and not subtraction
yeah so he's uh the left's very upset
about that
uh the squad they're very upset about it
and yeah like i said they're they're
saying what does this guy know about
about how to succeed politically he's
he's only
the most successful democrat politician
in the last several decades
which maybe isn't saying much but uh but
now they're there they've decided he
doesn't know what he's talking about
and you know i have no dog in this fight
really but i will say that
just to be to be clear about this barack
obama is
not saying that we shouldn't defund the
police
what he's saying is we shouldn't say
we're defunding the police
so what he's trying to say to the crazy
leftists is listen
you want to be crazy that's fine just
don't be so obvious about it
so i he he he's he's giving them advice
on how to brand this
um but they're not gonna listen to it
which is good
i'm glad they don't listen to him i
would encourage them to not listen to
him
uh because defund the police as a slogan
is a total loser the idea itself is also
a loser of course
but uh the only chance they have of
actually of actually
enacting this idea is to come up with a
different word for it a different phrase
and usually the left they're very good
at this
this is one thing the left is very good
at normally with euphemisms
coming up with different words that mean
something you know to to cloak the the
horrible things that they're doing
with abortion you know the number one
prime example of this think of all the
euphemisms that they have
covered this subject in reproductive
rights you know
which which is which is one big
euphemism because
as i've said many times abortion has
nothing to do with reproductive rights
because the abortion happens
after reproduction has already occurred
so
normally the left they do that they have
a lot of success in this case the
mistake they're making really is they're
just being honest
and and obama is saying stop being
honest guys
they're not interested in that five
finally um this isn't really a headline
per se but
i mentioned this because i i believe
that it's important to be a man of your
word
if you say you're going to do something
do it you know if you make a deal follow
through
that's what i believe but tyler conway
of bleacher report
it seems is not a man of his word
um he's a reporter for bleacher report
he tweeted to me a couple of days ago
during the discussion about sarah fuller
you know the girl who did that
hilariously bad kick for vanderbilt
and then proceeded to win you know she
kicked it 20 yards she won
sec special team player of the week and
everyone's hailing
what a great kick it was when of course
it was a horrible kick but um
and i've made that point and uh and
tyler conway wanted to white knight for
sarah be her knight in shining armor
defend her
so he issued a challenge to me he said
he said that i should kick a football
film it for twitter and if i do
he will donate to a charity of my choice
now i'm not one to back away from a
challenge
so i did as was requested i said kick a
football put on twitter
and i did i think we have the video it's
uh it's this is you you want to see real
athleticism
here it is right here let's play this
that's it now if you're listening and
you couldn't see the kick
you missed out because i
in my slippers in my kitchen nudge the
ball with my foot
i sent it sailing three
four feet easily um incredible kick
at least it was as good as sarah
fuller's kick but the main point is i
kicked the football i held up my that's
all he said he didn't say do it on a
football field
he didn't say he has to you know go
through the uprights or anything
that was the challenge but of course uh
he he backed away and um
and i i i i did that kick and i said
okay you can donate to the to
the national right to life committee um
big pro-life
organization and in order to uh
uh i guess his way of dunking on me
was to instead donate to planned
parenthood you donate a hundred dollars
to planned parenthood and that's how it
ended
up so he's not following through on what
he said but also i i just thought this
was interesting because
your your version of a dunk here is to
burn your own money essentially
is to waste a hundred dollars of your
own money sending it to a billion-dollar
corporation that by the way
already gets your money they they
already get 500 million dollars a year
from us they're going to give them 100
more they don't really need it
so essentially what he's saying is oh
yeah i'll show you
pulls out a hundred dollars sets it on
fire how do you like that
but um anyway there was my kick that's
my
athleticism maybe i should kick for
vanderbilt next they are right down the
street we're in nashville now so
you know i'm a big believer that uh we
have to continue
learning and and you know even even if
after you get out of school whether you
go to college or you don't i didn't go
to college
it doesn't matter you have to continue
learning and that means reading
uh you have to be you have to read in
order to learn and to be just an
interesting and well-adjusted
intelligent person the problem though
is finding the time to read and i can
say that that you know i'm usually a
pretty big reader but ever since i
i relocated to nashville uh
just the whole process of moving and
everything it's eaten up a whole lot of
my time i haven't had the same amount of
time that i usually do to sit down with
a book
and that's why i'm so happy that
thinker.org exists
thicker.org they're great they summarize
the key ideas from new and noteworthy
nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite-sized form
you can read or also listen to hundreds
of titles in a matter of minutes
and what they're going to do you know
we're talking about old classics like
how to win friends and influence people
recent bestsellers like 12 rules for
life jordan peterson's book of course
whatever it is and you know many many
books in between but what they're going
to do is they're going to they're going
to
tell you the information they're going
to give you the information the insights
the wisdom from those books
they offer just a large variety of
titles across many categories current
affairs politics business education
history that's one of my favorite
categories to go to relationships
i don't really need that category
because i'm perfect in all my
relationships as my wife will tell you
but you might need that so you can go
there too um and
then the other thing is you read the the
insights and maybe you you
think okay i wanna i wanna i wanna know
more you can go and buy the book
or maybe you feel like you've you've
gotten everything you need to out of
that you can go on to the next one
if you wanna challenge your
preconceptions expand your horizons
become a better thinker go to
thinkor.org that's
t-h-i-n-k-r-dot-org to start a free
trial
and download the app today let them know
you heard about them on the matt wall
show that's thinker.org
um yeah we've been telling you about uh
all the the benefits of being a daily
wire member and if you're not a daily
wire member not
yet now is the time to join because
we've got a lot of incredible stuff
just around the corner very close around
the corner in fact starting friday
december 4th
the michael knoll show is going five
days a week with more contents for
content for members to enjoy we're also
adding the entire prageru
uh catalog we've already got some prager
used stuff but we're putting it all on
dailywire.com it'll be there by the end
of the year for daily wire members
candace owen show from from prageru will
also be available and then she's going
to have her own show on the daily wire
live studio audience show which you got
to be a member
to fully enjoy that we're launching our
first feature film we've got
investigative journalism so much stuff
what you got to do is go to
dailywire.com subscribe
uh we're loud we're opinionated and
we're just having a good time
also uh yeah the ornament thing um
the uh the ornaments so get these uh get
these stupid ornaments
uh you we have we have the we're we're
adorable elves and you know i'm a big
i'm just a big fan of these right
i'm joking i'm being sarcastic because i
really i just love everything about
these ornaments it's been my dream
my whole life in fact to be converted
into an adorable elf
and to be hanging on a tree i can die a
happy man this is all i've ever wanted
in my life is this
you're watching the completion the
culmination of a man's life in front of
you right now
so text the word christmas to eight
three four zero zero to get your tree
decorated today with these
wonderful ornaments they're going fast
so get yours now
at dailywire.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to have to cancel
harry styles again or perhaps it's not
so much harry styles we're canceling as
the legions of cult-like
plebes who pretend that everything he
does is brilliant and beautiful
you probably recall the ruckus last week
when styles appeared in a magazine in
women's clothes
and candace owens who will soon be
having a show here on the daily wire
dared to suggest that men should not be
wearing
skirts and dresses and should instead be
masculine as god and nature intended
well the story sort of died down until
yesterday when stiles
issued a clap back to owens now i use
the term clapback because that is the
term
used by literally dozens of news outlets
in their headlines about the story
just google harry styles clapback and
then you know put
hit the news button dozens of these uh
of these headlines harry styles claps
back at candace owens
they used that term because we live in
an exceedingly stupid society
where once self-respecting news outlets
use teenage lingo in their headlines
but in any case um here's harry styles
and his clapback
his i'm told devastating brilliant
genius
incredible life-changing historic
clapback
possibly the cleverest comeback in the
history of comebacks and here it is it's
an it's an instagram post of harry
styles and what appears to be seinfeld's
puffy shirt
or that might be a blouse stitched
together from his grandmother's
tablecloth i'm not sure
and he's eating a banana and the caption
says
bring bring back manly men
which is what candace owens had said so
that's a clapback
now a few things here first of all are
we really going to pretend
that this man doesn't look stupid as
hell in that ridiculous outfit
the problem here is not that it's
womanly i've never seen a woman dress
like that or any human
if my wife walked into the room wearing
that
i would immediately stage an
intervention assuming that she's high on
heroin
second i want you to imagine something
for a moment just
imagine what would happen if a white
conservative male celebrity
what few exist were to issue a clap back
to a black liberal woman with a picture
of himself eating a banana
imagine how that would be received
imagine what assumptions would be made
you know we're at a point right now
where you can simply move your fingers a
certain way you can make a a circle with
your index and thumb
like this and you'll be accused of
sending racist messages
right now i'm sending a racist message
supposedly
almost anything is a racist dog whistle
these days so how is this picture of a
guy eating a banana
meant as a diss to a black woman not a
racist dog whistle now to be clear
i don't actually think that harry styles
meant it that way
um i don't really want to speculate on
what he's doing with that banana on
camera
much less what he'll do with it off
camera but we all know damn well what
kinds of speculation the media would be
doing if the politics were reversed here
the explosions of outrage would be
nuclear
the offender would have already issued
multiple tearful apologies
which would not be enough to stop him
from getting dropped from every project
and partnership he's a part of
that's how it would go but because
candace is a conservative none of that
applies
in fact harry styles he could probably
actually come out and say that he meant
it in a racist way
and it still wouldn't bother anyone on
the left or in the media because they
believe that if you're a conservative
you don't deserve basic human decency so
no treatment towards you can be out of
bounds
you could be shot dead as we've seen
by some antifa radical in the street and
they still won't say that you didn't
deserve it
so this goes for racist treatment too of
course and this is
double true for female conservatives and
black conservatives
and doubly doubly true for black female
conservatives because
they're not only horrible people for
being conservative but they're also
traitors
as the logic goes third point um
you know i'm talking about conservatives
here but candace's original point
is not really a conservative point it's
not a political point it's just a
normal natural human healthy
observation she's saying that she wants
men to be masculine
she wants men to live up to their
masculine potential
that's what she wants from men as a
woman
and i got news for you that's what
almost all women who have ever lived on
earth have wanted from men
that's not to say that all women have
the same taste in men
but generally speaking almost all women
the vast vast majority
since the dawn of human civilization
have desired that men be masculine
strong protectors providers
more stoic and rational than emotional
and sensitive
there are varying degrees there are
different tastes and priorities of
course
but there are also general statements we
can make about what most women
have wanted in men throughout history
just as there are general statements we
can make about what most men have wanted
in women
again since the dawn of time most men
have wanted women who are affectionate
maternal feminine empathetic caretakers
etc
now we can i suppose discuss whether
these ideals are good or right or
whatever
i would say they absolutely are good and
right and that societies which produce
feminine women and masculine men tend to
thrive in fact societies cannot thrive
unless there is some kind of general
idea about what roles men and women are
supposed to play within it
but my point even before we get to the
discussion about whether these
traditional gender role
role ideas are right is simply that they
are entirely
normal and natural and human
candace owens in saying that she finds
it ridiculous and off-putting
when men prance around in women's
clothes
is expressing the view of literally
billions of women on earth
past and present the left reacts to this
normal expression this normal view not
just by calling it wrong
but but by acting as though it's insane
irrational
bizarre crazy you aren't just incorrect
for thinking that men shouldn't
cross-dress
you're a freak a weirdo a nut job this
is the game they play
they do the same thing with drag queen
story hour with the children being given
hormone pills
people declaring themselves to be gender
queer pansexual aliens or whatever
they are the ones introducing this
bizarre and disturbing thing
but they act like you are the eccentric
wacko if you don't
immediately accept it they want to make
normalcy
seem abnormal they seek to make what is
natural seem perverse and what is
perverse
seem natural it is a massive game of
overcompensation you could say
and as a tactic it's extremely effective
you know they do something weird like
have a
drag queens dressed like tim burton
character show up to the library to read
lgbt propaganda to four-year-olds
and if you say yeah you know i don't
think i really
am in favor of this i don't i don't like
it
they go what you have a problem with
this
you don't like this what are you some
kind of degenerate
and it works lots of people upon
receiving that reaction
throw up their hands and say okay okay
never mind do what you want jeez
all right i forget i said anything
that is essentially what what most of
america says to the left it's
they don't agree with them they just say
all right just fine do what you want
comparatively few people have the
gumption and the guts to be met with
that onslaught and to say
yes i do have a problem with it now stop
being hysterical
you're the degenerate it's not me get
this crap out of the library
very few will do that even though the
vast majority of people think it's weird
and creepy
few will say it out loud and even fewer
will keep saying it even when the
pitchfork mob
shows up at their door and so the left
gets away with making what is normal
abnormal and what is abnormal normal
they are trying to
cancel normalcy in effect
but today they are canceled instead
for what it's worth which admittedly
probably is not much
but there it is and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there